critics continue to blast much of the
media for missing the mark on the Muller
report and one of the loudest anti media
voices is a frequent tweeter living at
1600 Pennsylvania Avenue
Fox News media analyst and host of Fox
News's media buzz howard kurtz looks at
the potential hit to the media's
reputation anticipation is building to a
fever pitch for two years the coverage
of the robert muller probe has been
dramatic
relentless and constantly suggesting
that president Trump's conduct was worse
than Watergate we do know that Donald
Trump senior has lied throughout this
investigation this goes to the heart of
everything we've been talking about for
the last couple of years the collusion
and the cover-up but as the
investigation ends with no indictments
for Russian collusion or obstruction of
justice
the press has come under harsh scrutiny
along with a series of high-profile
mistakes from ABC's Brian Ross making a
full sack you zation against Michael
Flynn the BuzzFeed saying Trump directed
Michael Cohen to lie to Congress and
condemnation czar coming from the right
and the left how in the world did
several major news organs networks
newspapers and so on devote so much time
to what turned out to be utterly
baseless speculation it was continuously
on MSNBC which let me just say should
have their top host on primetime go
before the cameras and hang their head
and shame and apologize for lying to
people it's time for CNN to issue an
apology
CNN banned me from their air because I
was being too fair the president
tweeting today the mainstream media is
under fire being scorned all over the
world as being corrupt and fake by
pushing the Russian collusion delusion
they truly are the enemy of the people
and the real opposition party I am
outraged by the behavior of these
networks okay
collusion collusion collusion collusion
pollution Leno collusion but today a
growing media counter-attack don't not
reporters at the New York Times or The
Washington Post or the wall street
journal or the broadcast networks for
doing their job right of course a
criminal probe yielding 37
diamonds had to be covered and of course
the lack of further charges doesn't mean
all those stories were wrong it's the
volume the tone and the doomsday
predictions that have the news business
very much on the defensive John
something will be chewing over for a
while Howie Kurtz for us tonight Howie
thanks